نتبع من تونس حيث انطلقت وسط العاصمه
التونسيه مظاهره احتجاجيه دعت اليها جبه
الخلاص الوطنيه المعارضه في ذكرى الاعلان
العالمي لحقوق الانسان وللتعبير عن ما
وصفته الجبهه برفض التونسيين للانقلاب
وتمسكهم بقيم الحريه ومبادئ الديمقراطيه
وكانت جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه قد نظمت منذ
اواخر تشرين الاول اكتوبر الماضي سلسله من
التحركات الميدانيه في عدد من المحافظات
بهدف العوده للديمقراطيه وحمايه الحريات
كما دعت الجبهه لمقاطعه الانتخابات
التشائيه المزمع اجرائها الاسبوع المقبل
التونسيه
هل اتضح كيف تتعامل قوه الامن مع تدهوره
اليوم
نعم جلال بالنسبه لي قوات الامن وتعاملها
مع هذه المظاهره الامر كما كان عليه في
التظاهرات والمسيرات السابقه التي نفذتها
جبهه الخلاصه الوطني هناك تمركز امني فوق
العاده هنا في شارع الحبيب بورقيبه وفي
الشوارع الفرعيه المؤديه اليه حتى ان
المشاركين في هذه المسيره اذكر الى سلك
طريق اطول من الطريق العادي من شارع
العمله او من ساحه العمله هنا في وسط
العاصمه التونسيه في اتجاه شارع حبيب
برجبال وصل المتظاهرون الى شارع برجيبه
اين سيتم تنفيذ هذا التجمع الذي يرفع فيه
انصار جبهه الخلاصه الوطني شعار ارحل في
حديثنا منذ قليل مع احد قيادي هذه الجبهه
عبد اللطيف المكي اكد بان كل المؤشرات
باللون احمر اليوم المؤشرات الاجتماعيه
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه وبذلك اليوم لا حل
للخروج من هذه الازمات في المشهد التونسي
الا برحيل قيس سعيد هذا بحسب القيادي في
جبهه الخلاص الوطني عبد اللطيف المكي بعد
قليل سيتم القاء كلمات من قبل قيادي
الجبهه جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه هذه الجبهه
وهذا العنصر المعارض الذي ينظم تحركات منذ
فتره طويله ومنذ شهر اكتوبر الماضي كان
جامعه الخلاصه الوطني قد نفذ سلسله من
التحركات ومن الاجتماعات الشعبيه في عديد
المدن والولايات التونسيه كان اخرها ولايه
الكافه التونسيه يوم السبت الماضي ايضا
اليوم كانت همم همم الاحزاب الخمسه ائتلاف
الاحزاب الخمسه المعارضه ايضا كانت ستنفذ
اليوم تحركا في العاصمه التونسيه لكن وقع
تاجي الى موعد لها كل هذه التحركات وكل
هذه المواقف السياسيه من المعارضه تتزامن
جلال مع دخول الحمله الانتخابيه
للانتخابات التشريعيه المقرر اجرائها في
السابع عشر من ديسمبر الجاري اسبوعها
الاخير ونذكر ان هذه الاحزاب وهذه الاطياف
المعارضه كجبه الخلاصه الوطنيه والاحزاب
الخمسه الرافضه
للانقلاب على حسب وصفها اعلنت منذ فتره
بانها تقاطع هذه الانتخابات التشريعيه
التي سيتم تنظيمها في 17 من الشهر
نجيب الشاب رئيس جامعه الخلاص يتحضر على
ما يبدو لالقاء كلمه شكرا لك مساء سنعود
اليك فورا ورود اي شيء جديد